et celui du public
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 24 février
le phénomène est-il en expansion
pourquoi plus particulièrement dans
l'essonne les questions sont nombreuses
au lendemain du décès de deux mineurs
tués en 24 heures dans des rixes entre
bandes rivales
le ministre de l'intérieur a envoyé sur
place une centaine de policiers des
gendarmes en renfort en renfort gérald
darmanin qui souligne le rôle du
mimétisme des réseaux sociaux ainsi que
les messagerie cryptée dans ces
violences
le couperet est tombé l'agglomération de
dunkerque confiner le week-end a
également annoncé olivier et veyran sur
place tout à l'heure et conférence de
presse de jean castex ce sera demain des
restrictions en local attendue alors que
la situation sanitaire est préoccupant
dans une dizaine de départements
gabriella talent ne cache pas son
inquiétude la quiétude du gouvernement
sur certains territoires et veut réagir
au cas par cas on leva rien aux
britanniques se propage très rapidement
l'union européenne demande ce soir à
caracas de revenir sur sa décision
d'expulser son ambassadrice
le venezuela a donné 72 heures à cette
dernière pour quitter le pays une
riposte diplomatique aux nouvelles
sanctions de bruxelles contre eux 19
fonctionnaires du gouvernement de
nicholas maduro pour leur rôle dans des
actes et décisions portant selon elle
atteinte à la démocratie et à l'état de
droit au venezuela les états unis brigue
un siège au conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu annonce du chef de la
diplomatie américaine anthony blinken
marquant l'abandon de la politique de la
chaise vide des aînés trump après
l'accord de paris l'organisation
mondiale de la santé c'est donc une
nouvelle institution que souhaiterait
intégrer l'administration baden
[Musique]
l'actualité en france marquée par la
mort de deux adolescents lors de rixes
en moins de 24 heures dont l'essonne
hier soir un adolescent a été tué
boussy-saint-antoine et un autre blessé
à la gorge dans ces violences un drame
qui intervient au lendemain du décès
dans ce même département d'une
collégienne tué d'un coup de couteau
dans le ventre
six adolescents âgés de 14 et 16 ans ont
été présentés aujourd'hui à un juge
d'instruction
la détention provisoire a été requise
pour l'un d'entre eux le ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'est rendu dans le
département hier soir a annoncé un
renforcement des effectifs de la police
se demander une centaine de policiers de
gendarmes supplémentaires de venir dans
le département
une soixantaine ici à tour depuis une
trentaine dans dans le lieu qui a connu
un deuxième drame pour que les choses
puissent s'apaiser qui puisse pas y
avoir de répliques ou de confrontation
nouvelle
la société n'est pas responsable de tout
et que les policiers les gendarmes les
maires ne peuvent pas faire à la place
des parents à une autorité qui consiste
à ne pas sortir seul le soir quand on
est un jeune adolescent d'aller suivre
des études ou une formation
professionnelle de ne pas avoir ce qui
était le cas et becky des armes blanches
des barres de fer
je pense que on conviendra tous ensemble
que ce n'est pas l'équipement naturel
d'un enfant de 13 ans de 14 ans dans la
rue est une ax à boussy saint antoine
dont qui a choqué bien évidemment
écouter un lycée en témoin de la scène
dont les coûte en fait
sortie et tout avec mes amis et puis
j'avais j'ai entendu qu'ils devaient
avoir une bagarre et ou de base moi je
vais pas trop y aller
j'ai un copain il voulait vraiment y
aller il était curieux de voir ce que
parce que c'est ce qui va se passer en
fait je prends de l'arrivée sur les
lieux et là on a vu c'était en fait
c'était comme un spectacle qu'il avait
une vingtaine de personnes qui regardent
et et voilà il était en train de ses
bottes début ça a commencé sur le
terrain de pétanque dont il a vu tous
courir vers le parking de
de la piscine et puis là j'ai vu
un jeune homme tombe au sol et il a
commencé à trembler moi j'ai pas su quoi
faire pour les regarder ça m'a choqué un
peu hélas après dirais que j'ai vu en
six ans que ses amis au téléphone
appeler à plus
les secours
nous offrons des partis font ça m'a
choqué j'ai préféré pas rester ici
c'est choquant et je meurs à 14 ans d'un
coup de couteau
par cannes
un jeune homme de 15 ans enfin six
essais
enfin choix
je n'ai pas les mots je sais pas je suis
prêt
il ya un deuxième jeune homme est là qu
actuellement dans le coma qui s'est pris
un coup de couteau dans la gorge juste
avant la vague a rejeté avec lui de
jouer
appareils
[Musique]
moi moi de moi je suis pas pour ça enfin
fini tu veux ça sert à rien du tout il
m'avait dit de venir avec lui moi je
suis dit non j'ai pas envie
là
ce contrat il se trouve à l'hôpital et
ses paroles
moi je trouve ça bête en fait c
alors le phénomène des rixes entre
bandes rivales et elle en expansion si
oui pourquoi comment l'endiguer surtout
dans l'essonne pour en parler place à
notre décryptage ce soir et nous sommes
avec aurélie gromaire du coudray
montceaux vice présidente du conseil
départemental de l'essonne président de
la france vraiment bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés guillaume
roux secrétaire départemental de l'unité
sgp police 91
bonsoir donc à vous aussi merci d'être
en direct
tout d'abord sur l'airé un renfort avant
d'aller dans le fond du débat 60
gendarmes ce soir de plus à saint chéron
30 policiers à boussy saint antoine ces
deux villes concernées par cette
dramatique actualité c'est ce qui va
ramener le calme
guillaume roux selon vous bah écoutez
c'est ce qui l'a empêché en tout cas on
espère les représailles parce que
malheureusement c'est ça peut être ça
peut être les raisons à la suite de tels
faits nous ce qu'on a besoin de ces des
effectifs permanents non pas des
effectifs éphémère alors oui c'est bien
aujourd'hui d'avoir répondu à part se
renforce et elle est nécessaire pour
justement essayer de rétablir le 15 mai
puis de le garder surtout c'est ce qui
est important mais ce qui est
souhaitable c'est un l'issue c'est
d'avoir des effectifs supplémentaires
surtout on départements l'essonne et
plus particulièrement en bourse pour
lever le dire on va y revenir justement
sur cette spécificité malheureusement
dans l'essonne mais tout d'abord mourir
à 14 ans pour une stupide histoire de
rivalité on entendu ce témoignage
poignant de ce lycéen très choqué bien
évidemment il ya quelque chose qui ne
tourne plus rond territoire de la
république aurait dit gros moi ce soir
si j'ai accepté de m'exprimer sur votre
plateau c'est d'abord pour par
solidarité pour ces deux jeunes victimes
évidemment et je peux dire que nom de
tous les estoniens évidemment de mes
amis maires de l'essonne des élus
départementaux ou encore des
responsables associatifs
notre grande tristesse et m'adresser
aussi ce soir aux familles
pour leur dire que évidemment nous
pensons à eux et aux drames qu'elle vive
avec cette jeune fille est ce jeune âme
qui ont été fauchés temps leur première
année de l'adolescence c'est intolérable
c'est inadmissible et c'est pourtant
bien une réalité est probablement une
réalité qui est explicable pas excusable
mais explicable
comment se fait-il aujourd'hui que dans
deux communes de l'essonne petites et
moyennes plutôt tranquille avec que de
telles guerres de bandes aboutissent
aujourd'hui à des mortes et à une telle
violence gratuite
il n'y a pas de phénomène spécifique qui
gagne notre pays et on croyait cela
plutôt réservés si je puis dire aux
états unis ou à des quartiers où père
ghettoïser et quand on regarde ces deux
communes ce n'est pas le cas et pour
régler des petits différends de gande on
hésite aujourd'hui pas à tuer
donc pour moi c'est d'une part le
passage à l'acte qui est devenu de plus
en plus banal par rapport à nos jeunes
et il nous fait immanquablement penser
aux réseaux sociaux
là où la haine des fermes les menaces de
nord se banalise et il semble n'y avoir
aucune limite et aujourd'hui à mon sens
internet met de l'huile sur le feu je
pense aussi également en troisième lieu
que le coc vide commencent à peser
lourdement sur les comportements des
adultes d d d d d d plus âgés aussi
qu'ils sont qui sont relativement
enfermés chez eux sans aucuns liens
sociaux mais aussi mais aussi de notre
jeunesse et les restrictions aujourd'hui
de liberté ne sont plus supportables
pour certains et on oublie aussi de se
préoccuper des autres questions et les
moyens de force de l'autre ce sont les
autres questions
les enquêtes pour tracer les jeunes
auteurs
la chaîne pénale et les sanctions contre
cette forme de délinquance
la grande couronne dont fait partie
l'essonne ne reçoit pas les moyens à la
hauteur de nos défis c'est un
département qui est très jeune c'est un
département qui a une population qui
augmente et avec un étalement urbain
donc aujourd'hui les annonces qui ont
été faites de deux policiers dont deux
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
c'est bien il faut répondre tout de
suite aux problèmes qui se posent
mais ça doit être totalement pérenniser
dans le temps
certes on ne peut pas répondre à un
problème et se dire ça va mieux et on
passe à autre chose
on va tâcher de le prendre tous et il ya
beaucoup d'idées dans ce que vous nous
dit on le débat dure encore un petit peu
on va tenter dé prendre dans l'ordre
tout d'abord en ce chiffre qui parle
selon la direction générale de la police
nationale au moins 80% des bandes
rivales violentes sont concentrées donc
en ile-de-france alors pas seulement
dans l'essonne même s'il ya une gravité
dans ce département en 2020 il y a eu en
france une hausse de 24% des rixes avec
357 affrontements entre bandes
guillaume roux donc c'est clair on se
pose pas la question de savoir si ça
augmenter puisque les faits parlent
d'eux mêmes
aurélie gros nous parler des réseaux
sociaux est ce que c'est votre avis
aussi la faute aux réseaux sociaux ce
passage à l'acte vous voyez vous une
différence réellement avec les années
internet si j'ose dire la faute
en tout cas ça ça favorise on le sait
très bien les réseaux sociaux sont un
moyen de donner une énorme de notre
dernier énormément de personnes on peut
tendre oui forcément les réseaux sociaux
c'est très très compliqué à pouvoir à
pouvoir gérer
après bien évident pour nous les
collègues par exemple je vais jouer je
vais prendre j'ai parlé de mes collègues
du renseignement parce que toutes ces
bombes là sont connus des services de
police bien évidemment elles sont elles
sont elles sont connues elles sont
identifiés aujourd'hui notre difficulté
à nous et à mes collègues de terrain
c'est de pouvoir anticiper ces faits ces
lettres ces problématiques et c'est pour
ça que j'en reviens à dire que la
solution est une des solutions tout cas
qui pourraient permettre d'anticiper et
puis d'éviter certaines fois que que ces
rixes interviennent et qu'on en arrive à
malheureusement
des manques comme c'était le cas hier
c'est de pouvoir contrôler ces
regroupements de personnes et pour
pouvoir les contrôler il faut plus de
monde sur le terrain et plus de
fonctionnaires de police et aujourd'hui
le val d'yerres qui comprend trois
communes brunoy mangeront draveil n'a
pas d'unité d'appui de gsp autres bst ce
que peut avoir corbeil essonnes evry ou
juive easy ou massy ou d'autres communes
comme sainte geneviève des bois donc
c'est très important de pouvoir
rapidement maîtres du monde sur le
terrain ça c'est un premier pas après
forcément toutes les solutions la police
tu les as pas pour endiguer
malheureusement ce phénomène là qui
existe depuis très longtemps c'est pas
le coc vide et peut-être une solution et
le fai locaux vides et pardon et
peut-être une un problème aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas c'est pas c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que ce phénomène existe
évidemment ça fait 20 ans que je suis
sur le département de l'essonne
et malheureusement ce phénomène de rixe
entre bandes j'ai toujours connu
par contre le niveau de violence a
augmenté sa c'est ça c'est indéniable
aujourd'hui c'est des armes à feu
c'est des couteaux donc on est là pour
faire pour faire mal c'est ce qu'ils
disent mais auront eu malheureusement et
on le voit encore hier et avant-hier
alors on allait à saint chéron dans
l'essonne où cette collégienne a trouvé
la mort charles beaudry s'est rendu sur
place notre reporter il a recueilli le
témoignage d'une habitante évidemment
choquée comme le reste de la population
sur place écoutez je suis né ici donc ça
fait 32 36 sont tous des gens viennent
ici parce que c'est réputé
calme logiquement après bon bah ça peut
arriver qu'il ya des petites bagarres
mais à ce point là c'est vrai que c'est
très très très rare il ya déjà eu des
des rixes avec des armes et pas de pas
de blessé grave on va dire on de mort
malheureusement ça nous a choqués
surtout que moi je connais je connais
son frère et sa mère donc persona ouais
ça m'a choqué ça rassure que les forces
de l'ordre passé c'est vrai que quand
des convois un petit attroupement bas ça
ça nous ça nous fait peur aussi sur le
coup et tout ce qui s'est passé donc
c'est avec les voir circuler ça nous
rassure et aurélie gros cette mère de
famille qui nous dit en substance que
nous disait guillaume roux et vous aussi
d'ailleurs on a toujours connu ces
phénomènes de violence mais pas à ce
point là
comment les expliquez guillaume roux
nous disait tout à l'heure que ces gens
là finalement ils étaient identifiés sur
les réseaux sociaux
qui sont-ils quel est leur profil ce
sont des jeunes des enfants même ils
sont quoi délaissés par leurs parents
ils traînent dans la rue expliqué nous
un petit peu le profil type c'est en
inde deux de ces jeunes
juste pour préciser tout à l'heure quand
j'ai parlé du coït je ne pense pas que
ce soit le colis de qui entraîne ce type
de 2,2 problème est que les
augmentations de deux rixes dans notre
territoire ne sont pas dues aux qu'ovide
par contre je pense qu'on se préoccupe
beaucoup moins nous élus locaux les
responsables
on se préoccupe beaucoup moins de ces
sujets-là entendre qu vide et
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai travail
engagé sur nos territoires sur les
territoires de grande couronne après
pour vous parler des jeunes parler des
jeunes on a parlé des réseaux sociaux
c'est qu'on a des jeunes qui sont
énormément sur les réseaux sociaux
le coc vide encore une fois n'arrange
rien qui aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faudrait une réponse sur ces réseaux
sociaux
quand vous voyez une police réel des
réseaux sociaux je sais que ça existe je
suis au courant mais je pense qu'il
faudrait accentuer la recherche sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est insensé qu'on puisse diffuser
aujourd'hui des appels au meurtre
alors qu on a par exemple vu les grands
réseaux sociaux fermer les comptes du
président des états unis parce que ces
propos devenez incitateurs à l'arrivée
aujourd'hui on ferme le compte de donald
trump mais on n'agit pas sur ces jeunes
qui qui qui se s'étale sur les réseaux
sociaux et se jette en pleine figure des
propos haineux
aujourd'hui on n'a aucun moyen d'agir
moi je demande au responsable d'internet
des réseaux sociaux gafa d'agir sur ce
problème là c'est essentiel à mon sens
on rirait s'il venait manger se découpe
en parler d'aidé
voilà je le répète ce sont des enfants
ils sont pas des parents ces enfants qui
serait quand même responsable un petit
peu aussi toujours demander à l'état oui
évidemment l'état une responsabilité
surveiller la sécurité
mais les parents on n'en parle pas dans
cette affaire bien sûr bien sûr ils ont
des parents est à mon sens ce mois-ci
mère de famille de quatre enfants donc
je suis une mère aussi donc je peux me
mettre à la place des parents un enfant
de 13 ans ou de 14 ans n'a rien à faire
à traîner dans les rues en bandes armées
c'est ça devient ça devient relativement
hallucinant effectivement le problème
des parents et de l'éducation à domicile
mais on sait très bien qu'une pour une
partie de ces jeunes là l'absence de
parents qui soit en capacité de pouvoir
s'occuper d'eux et est souvent souvent
le cas donc ça n'excuse rien parce que
moi je trouve qu'il n'ya pas d' excuses
devant de tels actes par contre
effectivement certains maires ont pris
des décisions quant aux aides sociales
sur sur les parents dont les enfants
commettraient des des délits important
je pense qu'à un moment donné il faudra
réfléchir conjointement tous ensemble
pour que la responsabilité des parents
soient soient mises en avant dans ce
type de problème bien au dessus on est
on est d'accord les parents et/ou leurs
responsabilités sait on peut pas
toujours dire que c'est l'état les
enseignants le manque de culture le
manque de 1 lice hier je ne suis pas en
train de dire ça moi j'essaye de donner
la réponse politique
or je ne suis pas dans les familles elle
est effectivement à un moment de livres
tête avoir une réponse très claire avec
ses parents qui n'assument pas leur rôle
et à ce moment-là peut-être leur couper
les aides comme l'ont fait certains
maires dans
hors commune il ya aussi la chaîne
pénale dont vous parliez ohrid hygro
tout à l'heure guillaume roux beaucoup
de réactions évidemment après ces drames
beaucoup parlent de la primo délinquants
c'est à dire ses premiers actes qui
selon certains ne seraient pas assez
sanctionné donne un sentiment d'impunité
c'est une partie du problème selon vous
également
ça fait partie la réponse pénale adaptée
aujourd'hui elle doit alors forcément
doit forcément être sur une table pour
en discuter parce que c'est un vrai
problème
effectivement aujourd'hui ce phénomène
de bandes qui qui vont le voir le niveau
de violence et à augmenter
il faut absolument trouver une réponse
adaptée une réponse pénale adaptée pour
pour ces jeunes parce que le problème
c'est que ce qui est ce qui est un petit
peu énervant c'est que nous nous
policiers et syndicats on le dénonce
depuis très longtemps on le voit de
toute façon que cette nouvelle
génération cette nouvelle délinquance à
paris depuis un petit moment voilà on le
voit bien aujourd'hui les collègues qui
subissent des guets-apens avec des jets
de cocktails molotov ou des tirs de
mortier ce sont des jeunes du même âge
d'ailleurs ce qui était sans doute hier
dans la bagarre peuvent participer à ce
genre de ce genre de faits donc voilà ça
c'est des choses qu'on avait déjà
dénoncé depuis longtemps et j'ai peur
que j'ai plan qu'encore une fois on ne
faisait pas pris au sérieux on n'est pas
pris le phénomène au sérieux on a pensé
que c'était quelque chose qui pouvait se
régler tout seul absolument pas et je
pense encore une fois que ça ça passe
par une discussion et la réponse pénale
adaptée pour ce genre de faits en est
une en tout cas avec après
l'augmentation des effectifs de police
parce qu'encore une fois je le répète
c'est très importante pour nous sur le
terrain de pouvoir endiguer ce genre de
situation je veux dire la présence
policière est là toujours dissuader dans
les quartiers vous passe et envoie la
police
aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya des
quartiers il ya des zones où on la voit
moins et le val d'isère c'est le cas
parce que ils nous demandent des
effectifs alors sur le département en
général ça c'est sûr mais encore plus
sur le val d'yerres et malheureusement
hier c'est un drame qui nous fait encore
parler de sang et or et les gros le mot
de la fin la peur de la police mais
aussi
au final la peur des condamnations
vraiment sévère de la police
effectivement et la réponse pénale sur
ces jeunes-là et essentiel je pense que
moi je ne suis pas je ne suis pas une
partisane de renvoyer ces jeunes dans
les prisons puisqu'on sait que souvent
ce n'est pas la solution mais des
maisons d'éducation où il sera envoyé
quand j'aurai une peine pour vraiment
pour mineurs où il n'y a aucun mélange
avec avec des adultes me semblerait très
adapté on a un grand nombre de casernes
pour été fermés on pourrait les
transformer pour ces jeunes là
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui ont qui
commettent des faits ont un sentiment de
surpuissance parce qu'ils savent très
bien qu'au bout du compte ça n'ira pas
très loin donc les policiers font leur
travail prennent des risques
c'est à dire que ils vont au front ils
vont aller au contact de la population
souvent en sous-effectif et par la suite
on sait que la réponse pénale ne va pas
suivre derrière aujourd'hui c'est toute
la chaîne
la chaîne de pénale qui est à revoir et
effectivement les effectifs donnée par
monsieur darmanin hier au cul ce sont
les seuls doivent être pérennisés
car vous parliez du taux du val d'yerres
mais c'est sur l'ensemble de l'essonne
qu'il y a un problème d'effectif moi je
le vois dans ma commune on peut pas dire
que les gendarmes soient très bien doté
en effectif et clairement il faut que la
chaîne pénale il réponse
il ya une réponse pénale à chaque acte
de ces jeunes mères parce que tu es
jeune qui se balade avec avec des armes
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas tolérable
merci bois est dans un sentiment
d'impunité
merci beaucoup à tous les deux rigolions
ou d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir accepté
ce décryptage ce soir
la situation sanitaire à présent prise
de parole aujourd'hui de gabriel attali
l'issue des traditionnelles conseil de
défense sanitaire et conseil des
ministres auquel on sait désespérément
habitués mais également celle de
ministre de la santé en fin d'après-midi
à dunkerque pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons touba bonnet en direct de
l'elysée bonsoir
thomas les indicateurs sanitaires qui se
dégradent sur une partie du territoire
donc et le gouvernement qui prévoit
désormais des mesures rapides et fortes
pour endiguer la progression du virus
oui avec un confinement le week end
annonce est donc cet après midi par
olivier rend en visite à dunkerque un
confinement le week-end qui prend effet
dès cette semaine le résultat d'une
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
dans la ville du nord selon les dires du
ministre de la santé en ce moment chaque
semaine un habitant de dunkerque sur 100
est contaminée par le coronavirus c'est
long cette raison qui a poussé les
autorités à prendre de nouvelles mesures
je propose d'écouter le ministre de la
santé
ainsi à dunkerque et dans la communauté
de communes des hautes flandre ce qui
représente environ 250000 habitants à
compter de vendredi soir et jusqu'au
lundi matin un confinement sera
désormais adapter le week-end donc dès
ce week end les déplacements resteront
possibles pour certains motifs tels que
des achats de première nécessité ou
encore des motifs médicaux vous
connaissez ces motifs et les commerces
autre que les commerces alimentaires
seront fermées après la ville de nice
c'est donc désormais la ville de
dunkerque et concernés par des mesures
de restrictions sanitaires
supplémentaires un peu plus tôt dans la
journée le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriel à dallas donc tenu un point
presse à l'issue du conseil de défense
sanitaire et du conseil des ministres
plusieurs pistes sont sur la table nous
dit on met une option est à cette heure
écartée celle d'un recompte finement
nationale écouter gabriela talent tous
nos efforts tous nos efforts doivent se
poursuivre pour éviter d'avoir à décider
d'un nouveau confinement nationale sans
évidemment certitude que nous y
parviendrons mais depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois c'est
ce que vous m'entendez vous dire mais
nous avons une stratégie de cette
stratégie je le disais c'est la capacité
à respecter les gestes barrières les
règles du couvre-feu et thomas des
mesures sont donc attendus très vite
demain le premier ministre jean castex
de tiendra une conférence de presse à
18h
[Applaudissements]
oui une prise de parole du premier
ministre ce jeudi à 18 heures qui
devrait donc être l'occasion d'annoncer
des mesures ciblées c'est la stratégie
du gouvernement répondre de manière
locale en privilégiant des mesures
coercitives à l'échelle d'un département
ou d'une agglomération la question est
donc de savoir quels seront ces mesures
et qui pourraient être concernées selon
gabriel attal la situation s'est
dégradée ces derniers jours dans une
dizaine de départements sur le
territoire et un chiffre en atteste
31500 nouveaux cas positifs ont été
relevées ces dernières 24 heures en
france une chose est sûre en tout cas
toujours selon gabriel attal un
allègement des restrictions n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour et ce y compris dans les
régions où le taux d'incidence est plus
faible qu'ailleurs le gouvernement qui
espère parallèlement intensifier la
campagne de vaccination dès demain les
médecins de ville pourront procéder aux
injections
merci thomas bonnet rester avec nous
dans quelques instants nous partirons au
venezuela l'union européenne demande ce
soir à caracas de revenir sur sa
décision d'expulser son ambassadrice et
puis direction les états unis il brigue
un siège au conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu annonce aujourd'hui du
chef de la diplomatie américaine anthony
blinken
[Musique]
et
le
et s
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant tu comprends que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soient pas
publics parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est on dirait qu il y
a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des tâches
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois comme on s'est donné un autre
pas seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout opposait se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
j'entendais pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa parents
pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez les
rapports se tendent un peu plus entre le
venezuela et l'union européenne
bruxelles demande à caracas de revenir
sur sa décision d'expulser son
ambassadrice
un peu plus tôt ce mercredi le pouvoir
vénézuélien lui demander quitter le pays
une réaction forte aux sanctions prises
ce lundi par les 27 à l'encontre du
gouvernement de nicholas maduro
les détails avec solène de la trois
jours pour quitter le pays
c'est le délai laissé par le
gouvernement des mesures et lien à
l'ambassadrice de l'union européenne est
aujourd'hui sur décision du président
nicholas maduro
nous avons remis en main propre à madame
isabelle brillante elle a sauté montagne
un point qui a été ces dernières années
la chef de la délégation de l'union
européenne au venezuela une déclaration
de persona non grata des acws à la
convention de vienne ce conformément à
la convention de vienne sur les
relations diplomatiques
elle dispose de 72 heures pour quitter
le territoire vénézuélien
une décision réclamée à l'unanimité par
le parlement le pouvoir exécutif a
déclaré que la chef de la délégation de
l'union européenne dans la république
bolivarienne du venezuela
isabelle brillante pedro sein est
persona non grata je lève mais demain
pour demander que la représentante de
l'union européenne soit déclaré persona
non grata
mais demain pour exhorter à la révision
des conditions dans lesquelles le bureau
de l'union européenne existe ici
baisieux la belle étoile et réviser
l'accord sur la présence de la
représentation européenne à caracas
c'est l'autre geste fort demandés par le
parlement largement dominé par le parti
socialiste unifié du venezuela du
président nicholas maduro en cause les
sanctions infligées ce lundi par
bruxelles à 55 aux fonctionnaires et
responsables politiques du gouvernement
de maduro cette menace pesait sur le
venezuela depuis janvier dernier l'union
européenne entend ainsi sanctionné son
rôle dans des actes et décisions portant
selon elle atteinte à la démocratie et à
l'état de droit ce mercredi
bruxelles a demandé à caracas de revenir
sur sa décision
le venezuela ne surmontera la crise
actuelle que par la négociation et le
dialogue bleus est prête à faciliter
cela met une tête décision ne va pas
aider
caracas n'est pas un cas isolé ce lundi
l'union européenne a décidé de
sanctionner plusieurs autres
gouvernements pour non respect des
droits de l'homme à l'instar de la
russie le venezuela rejette en bloc les
mictions de bruxelles dans ses affaires
intérieures en lui renvoyant sa
représentante
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanche maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir quand
on crée sans merci d'être avec nous
l'explosion de l'ambassadrice de l'union
européenne
est-ce que c'est finalement vraiment une
riposte aux sanctions prises ce lundi
parole l'union européenne à l'encontre
du venezuela où peut-on y voir une autre
lecture
oui c'est une riposte bien entendu un
peu un peu brutale et certainement
symbolique aux mesures décidées par
l'union européenne de réduire la liberté
d'accès au territoire de l'union
européenne pour 19 personnalités
vénézuélienne et bien sûr comme vous la
victoire
si on ajoute celles qui avaient été
sanctionnés plus tôt dans pour d'autres
sujets en tout il ya cinquante cinq
personnalités vénézuélienne qui ne
peuvent plus avoir de visa schengen ni
de comptes bancaires dans l'union
européenne
j'imagine d'ailleurs qu'elles viennent
rarement dans l'union européenne et que
si elles avaient un compte en banque
quelque part en europe il serait depuis
longtemps partie ailleurs probablement
en asie
mais cela dit c'est vrai que le
parlement européen s'est senti visé par
ces sanctions
puisque les dix neuf personnalités qui
ont été qui ont été visés hier et bien
parmi elles il ya deux parlementaires et
le motif général de ses 19 sanctionné
c'est le fait que les élections
législatives du 6 décembre dernier on
était un peu particulière particulière
pourquoi parce que les partis
d'opposition avaient des scuds décidé de
boycotter cette élection et que par
conséquent il ya eu 70 % d'abstention
donc les députés ont été élus par 30%
des électeurs et bien entendu dans ces
conditions 90% des sièges ont été
attribués au parti de monsieur maduro et
de l'union peine est pas est pas la
seule à critiquer cette pratique les
états unis le canada mais aussi des pays
d'amérique latine comme la colombie ou
comme le panama ont également fortement
critiqué cette pratique un peu
particulière les élections législatives
alors maintenant madame isabelle bryant
et doit partir d'ici samedi
sauf si sauf si monsieur maduro se
ravise
car c'est le deuxième essai de monsieur
malraux il avait déjà il avait déjà
donné la même peine à madame brillante
et au mois de juin dernier et le 29 juin
ils lui avaient donné 72 heures pour
quitter le territoire et puis pour des
raisons diverses il s'est ravisé
deux jours plus tard et elle a pu rester
cette fois ci ça sans doute plus
difficile compte tenu en effet de la
position prise par le parlement et qui
sont en fait et les partisans de
monsieur magro qui sont sa base
politique et il est possible que cette
fois ci sur une major haut ne revienne
pas sur cette décision
mais la délégation que dirigeait madame
brillante et pour le moment n'est pas
expulsé n'est pas fermée et continuera à
travailler y compris sur les questions
humanitaires qui intéresse beaucoup
les vénézuéliens alors quelle
conséquence l'expulsion disait belle
brillante et pedrosa
bah la tentation à bruxelles
si monsieur maduro ne revient pas sur sa
décision ce sera sans doute celle de
toute diplomatie c'est la réciprocité
c'est à dire de retirer son agrément à
l'ambassadrice du venezuela auprès de
l'union européenne
il se trouve que c'est aussi une femme
d'ailleurs paraît-il tout à fait
remarquable et qui est également
accrédité auprès de la belgique et du
luxembourg
donc s'il y avait s'il devait y avoir un
retrait de son accréditation auprès de
l'union européenne
elle pourrait cependant rester
évidemment à bruxelles puisqu'elle est
accrédité auprès du gouvernement belge
et du gouvernement du grand duché du
luxembourg
je ne vois pas beaucoup d'autres
conséquences puisque encore une fois
comme je vous le disais sauf si le
gouvernement vénézuélien demandé la
fermeture complète de la mission de
l'union européenne
les gens qui travaillaient avec madame
présenter continueront de travailler sur
leurs différents sujets qui sont des
sujets de coopération avec les
vénézuéliens et par ailleurs les
ambassades des états membres
naturellement continue de fonctionner et
les ambassadeurs sont toujours sont
toujours en place heureusement
heureusement d'ailleurs
alors une crise diplomatique certes mais
les vénusiens l'événement olala je vais
y arriver mais mes yeux ayant donc ça
bah écoutez c'est assez simple
actuellement il ya encore 30 millions de
vénézuéliens
mais il y a cinq ans il y en avait 35 en
fait 5 millions sont partis un million
et demi sont dans le pays voisin et sont
réfugiés en colombie il n'est pas
pourtant un pays de tout repos mais ils
ont préféré quitter le venezuela
et puis d'autres sont partis vers des
pays plus lointains certains vers
l'europe en passant par l'espagne
puisque ils ont en commun la langue
espagnole et les vénézuéliens sont
aujourd'hui le venezuela est aujourd'hui
le deuxième pays d'origine des
demandeurs d'asile
dans l'union européenne ce qui est un
véritable problème pour l'union
européenne et c'est la situation
politique et économique du venezuela
il crée ce flux de départs vers des
horizons les horizons plus plus plus
souriants ou plus accueillants et
effectivement on peut on peut dire que
le venezuela a perdu 60 % de son produit
national brut en cinq ans ce qui est
énorme que l'année dernière en 2020 la
monnaie vénézuélienne a connu une
inflation gigantesque d'ailleurs
inimaginable 3000% d'inflation ce qui
est vu nulle part ailleurs et le fmi a
d'ailleurs refusé de concéder à un prêt
ou une aide au venezuela
alors que monsieur maduro demandait au
mois de mai dernier cinq milliards de
dollars et le fmi a dit qu'aucune des
conditions étaient remplies pour que
c'était de soin accordé au venezuela
donc le venezuela dans une situation
économique dramatique avec une industrie
pétrolière autrefois florissante qui
aujourd'hui est totalement obsolète
aucun investissement n'a été fait par
conséquent toutes les machines sont
obsolètes et la productivité très
faibles
et c'est la même chose dans d'autres
secteurs de l'économie un jour
évidemment le venezuela aura besoin de
l'aide de pays extérieurs pour rétablir
son économie pour rétablir la
productivité dans le domaine pétrolier
et dans les autres domaines et
économique
merci expert en relations
internationales
le bilan est lourd en équateur au moins
79 morts dont trois prisons théâtre
presque simultanée de violence sans
précédent des violences attribuées par
les autorités à des rivalités entre
gangs un phénomène récurrent dans le
pays
les détails avec grégoire dos et c'est
une journée effroyable qu'ont vécu ce
mardi trois prisons surpeuplées de
l'équateur l'origine de ces violences
inouïes d'après les autorités
des rixes entre bandes rivales composée
notamment de narcotrafiquants et la
polio nous pouvons compter aujourd'hui
sur le soutien total de la police
nationale environ 800 policiers ont aidé
à reprendre le contrôle et à rétablir
l'ordre dans les centres de détention
d'autres groupes au stand aux deux
groupes tentent de prendre la tête de la
lutte contre la criminalité dans les
centres de détention à l'intérieur d'un
centre opérationnel à legata si les
violences sont récurrentes dans le
système carcéral équatorien celles ci
sont particulièrement meurtrières et à
l'extérieur c'est un sentiment de
panique qui a gagné les proches des
détenus pendant les émeutes
tout le monde sait que tous les
prisonniers ont un téléphone
nos enfants nous ont dit hier soir
qu'ils étaient en danger et qu'à tout
moment une émeute allait se produire
je ne peux pas communiquer avec lui je
le sais rien je demande qu'il me dise ce
qu'il s'est passé
si mon fils va bien mais personne ne me
donnent l'information ceux qui sont ici
à l'intérieur ne sont pas des animaux ce
sont des personnes je sais qu'ils ont
commis des délits mais ils doivent avoir
conscience que nous sommes des humains
eux n'ont pas de coeur
ils n'ont pas d'enfants malgré des
politiques de diminution du nombre de
prisonniers
la surpopulation carcérale atteint
toujours 30% dans les établissements
pénitentiaires
ils sont par ailleurs seulement 1500
gardien à surveiller les trente-huit
mille personnes incarcérées dans le pays
les états unis veulent réintégrer le
conseil des droits de l'homme de l'onu
annonce ce matin du chef de la
diplomatie américaine anthony blinken
qui intervenait par visioconférence
devant l'instance onusienne à l'occasion
de sa 46ème édition une centaine de pays
participent depuis hier d'administration
trump avait claqué la porte de ce
conseil en 2018 vous propose d'écouter
le secrétaire d'état avec les états unis
ne prétendent pas être parfait mais nous
nous efforçons chaque jour de nous
améliorer de nous responsabiliser de
devenir une union plus parfaite
nous relevons nos propres défis de
manière ouverte et transparente pour que
le monde entier puisse en prendre
connaissance
c'est parfois douloureux parfois l'est
mais nous traitons nos problèmes
ouvertement et pleinement et pour en
parler nous sommes avec gérald olivier
analyse franco-américain bonsoir gérald
olivier merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france
alors ça y est la politique de la chaise
vide eux définitivement abandonnée par
joe biden oui mais c'était une
définition une décision qui était
attendue c'est pas une surprise puisque
il avait annoncé durant sa campagne que
seule intention était de réintégrer ce
corps ya une quinzaine de jours il y
avait une led qui avait été un nom qui a
été envoyée
donc vos conseils des nations unies sur
les droits de l'homme pour signifier
cette demande de retour alors c'est un
retour avec un statut d'observateur
mais c'est surtout manifestement le
contre-pied encore une fois d'une prise
de position de donald trump puisque
donald trump lui avait décidé de quitter
ce conseil il ya à peu près deux ans à
l'époque il se plaignait
de plusieurs choses il se plaignait
d'une part dada d'une prise de position
systématiquement anti-israéliennes de
manière totalement disproportionnée il
se plaignait aussi du fait qu'au sein du
conseil un certain nombre de pays était
toujours exempt de toute critique alors
que leur palmarès ont à dire en matière
de droits humains n'étaient pas été loin
d'être parfait donc il avait décidé de
ne plus cautionner un tel corps et de
demander des réformes avant de revenir
aujourd'hui byden réintègre 7 ce conseil
sans demander aucune réforme en dix ans
exactement comme l'avait fait barack
obama il ya une dizaine d'années je
rappelle que le conseil ce conseil en
fait date de 2006 il avait pris la
succession à l'époque de ce qui
s'appelait la commission sur les droits
de l'homme et cette commission ayant
perdu beaucoup de sa crédibilité
kofi annan le secrétaire général de
l'urd des nations unies à l'époque avait
décidé de la dissoudre et de la
remplacer par ce conseil est au départ
de george bush avait décidé de ne pas
intégrer les états unis à ce conseil
pour voir comment ils allaient se
comporter
obama en 2009 avait rejoint le conseil
trump en était sorti hebeisen y revient
alors qu'on a bien vu que la présence
des etats-unis sous obama n'avait
absolument pas permis à ce conseil de se
réformer et donc on se demande un petit
peu quel sera l'objectif ou le résultat
de cette réintégration
alors l'objectif peut être redevenir le
gendarme du monde je ne sais pas en tout
cas le discours était plutôt
moralisateur tout à l'heure il y avait
les bons
les bonnes démocratie les mauvaises est
ce qu'on peut s'attendre justement à ce
que les états unis reviennent au centre
du jeu c'était de toute façon ce
qu'avait dit joe biden non je ne serais
pas d'accord avec votre formulation
quand vous dites que les états unis
reviennent au centre du jeu je veux
quand même détruire une sorte de fausse
idée qui s'est installé sous la
présidence de trump qui était que les
états unis avaient quitté le centre du
jeu c'est faux en fait
donald trump avait quitté un certain
nombre d'organisations et d'organismes
qu'il jugeait inefficace qu'il jugeait
corrompus qu'ils jugeaient peut-être
même néfaste voire négatif aux intérêts
américains
je pense par exemple à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
mais je pense également à l'accord de
paris sur le climat et donc à cette
commission sur les droits de l'homme
donc les états unis ne se retirait pas
du jeu il se retirait d'organisation qui
pour eux ne servait pas l'intérêt
international et encore moins d'intérêt
des états unis la position de
l'administration buydens vous avez
raison de le souligner est beaucoup plus
moralisatrices joe biden a eu un certain
nombre de deux mots durant son son
discours d'investiture où il évoquait
l'idée que les états unis souhaitaient à
nouveau être une force pour le bien dans
le monde
il n'a pas donné sa définition du bien
mais ça veut dire en effet que ils vont
réintégrer un certain nombre de scènes
reprendre un certain nombre de dialogues
ce qu'on sait malheureusement c'est que
ces dialogues n'aboutissent pas parce
que lui enfin les nations unies remonte
à l'après deuxième guerre mondiale
le conseil en question à plus de 25 ans
et un précédent où on a bien vu que son
efficacité en matière de gestion des
droits de l'homme était loin d'être
parfaite donc encore une fois on se
demande bien ce à quoi cette
réintégration américaine apportera vous
avez vos qu'il serait vain puisque dans
un train avait quitté vous l'avez
rappelé l'organisation l'accusons
d'hypocrisie et de s'acharner contre
israël cette phase il le message est
bien différent quelles conséquences pour
l'état hébreu
il est évident que les relations entre
l'administration bas et donne à israël
rien à voir avec ce qu'elle était sous
de tant de mal trump sous donald trump
netanyahu était son premier allié et et
trump et est le premier défenseur
d'israël il y avait entre entre deux un
accord sur énormément de poids ils
formaient un binôme très très favorable
aux positions israéliennes on a bien vu
que c'est pas du tout le cas sous
l'administration brydon rappelons que
joe biden le président des états unis a
attendus pratiquement un mois avant de
passer son premier coup de téléphone à
netanyahou et il a souligné qu'il était
favorable au processus engagé par les
accords d'abrams la fameuse fameux
processus de paix qui a été engagée ou
luka en partiellement abouti en 2020 ce
l'administration donald trump
donc pour l'instant jobs hayden n'a pas
désavoué ces accords il a souhaité
travailler dans leur cadre mais il a
bien souligné qu'il envisageait une
solution à deux états est manifestement
l'administration baril donnent va être
beaucoup plus regardante quant aux
soutiens qu'elle va apporter à l'état
d'israël
donc israël reste un allié essentiel des
états unis mais on en revient à une
relation beaucoup plus distendus qu'elle
n'était sous donald trump un changement
aussi le 10 courant vers l'arabie
saoudite et les interlocuteurs sur place
exactement exactement c'est un petit peu
l'autre l'autre côté de ce l'autre face
de cette même pièce
en vérité la politique américaine au
moyen orient sous donald trump
elle était axée sur deux piliers qui
était israël d'un côté et l'arabie
saoudite pour le monde arabe
et on a vu que joe biden a dénoncé un
contrat d'armement passé avec l'arabie
saoudite
au passage il a également dénoncé un
contrat d'armement avec les émirats
arabes unis contrat qui avait été signé
dans le cadre de la reconnaissance
d'israël par par les émirats donc une
décision qui peut également remettre en
compte un certain nombre de relations
établies par l'administration troc mais
on voit clairement que ces deux piliers
de la politique américaine au
proche-orient pose problème pour
l'administration
bart hayden alors qu'en même temps il
parle de réouvrir odeurs
renouer le dialogue avec l'iran donc on
a des positions qui sont à l' inverse de
ce qu elles ont été pendant quatre ans
et des positions qui non seulement
prennent le contre-pied d'administration
précédentes mais encore une fois
remettent en cause un certain nombre
d'acquis sans que l'on sache quelle est
la stratégie ni quel est l'objectif
final de ces changements
un discours enfin très durs envers la
réussir de la part d' anthony blinken
jusqu'à quel point va se durcir la
relation russo américaines écoutez on
voit clairement qu'au département d'état
vous avez un certain nombre de deux
comment dirais-je de penser qu'ils sont
établis et que donald trump n'a pas
réussi à inverser et la première de ses
pensées c'est une attitude d'hostilité
ouverte envers la russie
s'il ya bien eu un échec à la politique
étrangère américaine de l'administration
tram ça a été celui de combattre cet
état au fond qui fait que 30 ans après
la fin de la guerre froide alors que le
monde a considérablement changé
alors que le premier défi des états unis
le premier rival économiques
stratégiques et idéologiques aux aides
des états unis au 21e siècle ce n'est
plus la russie mais c'est déjà la chine
eh bien on constate au département
d'état et un certain nombre de positions
qui n'ont qui sont ancrées et qui ne
peuvent pas évoluer
donc j'ai envie de vous dire que tant
que du côté russe vladimir poutine sera
l'homme du pays je ne vois pas la
position avait tant qu'on aura les
démocrates à washington ou dominant au
sein de l'exécutif et du département
d'état je ne vois pas la position
américaine évoluer favorablement la
russie ce n'est pas une position qui est
plus hostile mais qui est beaucoup plus
méfiante et qui refusent toujours une
forme de coopération stratégique qui à
mon avis aujourd'hui se justifierait sur
beaucoup de points olivier
analyse franco américain pour cette
analyse complète merci à vous et la 46e
édition du conseil des droits de l'homme
de l'onu toujours venu également des
échanges les questions environnementales
le racisme ou encore la crise sanitaire
sujet sur lequel est revenu sergueï
lavrov lors de son intervention le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
déploré certaines stratégies de
communication en pleine pandémie à
moscou la correspondante antoine gayraud
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères dans son intervention a
dénoncé à plusieurs reprises l'égoïsme
des pays occidentaux ou encore leur
volonté de tirer des avantages
politiques de la situation sanitaire
actuelle il est également revenu sur les
dernières sanctions imposées contre
moscou des sanctions ciblées contre des
fonctionnaires des hauts responsables
liée à l'emprisonnement alexeï navalni à
son retour à moscou de façon implicite
sergey lavrov a donc évoqué le sujet en
dénonçant les campagnes d'information à
charge contre certains pays
aujourd'hui l'espace médiatique mondiale
est en train de devenir un lieu de
promotion d'intérêts géopolitiques
mercantile les campagnes agressives de
fake nous sape la stabilité politique
interne des états souverains provoque
des troubles et des actes de violence
dans la foulée l'annoncé de ces
nouvelles sanctions contre moscou a été
commentée cette fois de manière plus
explicite par la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe
la décision de l'union européenne
d'étendre les sanctions personnelles
visant la russie en raison de la
situation concernant navalni n'est qu'un
cirque est une histoire jouée d'avancé
comme il est de coutume dans les
relations diplomatiques entre et à toute
nouvelle sanction appelle la plupart du
temps à des contres sanctions
équivalentes mais cette fois ci cela
pourra aller plus loin le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères a laissé
entendre que la russie pourrait tout
bonnement au rompre ses relations avec
l'union européenne si les autorités
jugent qu'il n'existe pas de coopération
d'égal à égal entre moscou et bruxelles
est restée avec toi dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la
situation sanitaire en france olivier
vers en annonçant le confinement le
week-end à dunkerque dès ce vendredi
soir comme
qui a été décidé dans les alpes
maritimes jean castex tiendra une
conférence de presse demain alors que la
dégradation de la situation impose selon
le gouvernement des mesures rapides et
fortes
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est dans l'hymne
quel rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a
vu et big for books les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce que quelqu'un s'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à dole à
des entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
on a le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
majorque mâcon il passe un tour de
tracts avec nous que nos campagnes il
faut savoir c'est une différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham changer les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve était
le seul à pouvoir créer induction d'une
paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran tu n'iras les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
mais ça imaginer la quantité de gens qui
tombent ici tous en même temps
en un instant ils sont tous tombés
c'est vraiment incroyable que tant de
soldats soient enterrés ici dans les
bois au lieu d'être et chez eux avec
leur famille quand j'étais petit ma mère
m'a dit qu'un de nos parents evgeny
osipov avait disparu avec son sous marin
il ya une torpille à tribord
on a reçu un avis de décès il a été
porté disparu au début on a attendu
un juger par ses bottes c'est un soldat
soviétique ses ouailles
je veux que le soldat soit identifié
pour qu'on puisse trouver une plaque
d'identité militaire des médailles ou
autre chose
le sort du soldat est probablement la
chose la plus importante dans nos
recherches
[Musique]
depuis des décennies il s'est imposé
comme la devise incontournable dans le
commerce international le dollar peut-il
être détrôné détrôner pas encore c'est
pas quelque chose d'à ce fait en lice jo
ce que veut faire les chinois c'est
qu'ils veulent des de l'arizona j parce
que le dollar à des folies qui viennent
de washington ce qu'on dit le chinois
ben si ça vous fait rien on va régler
nos problèmes de liquidité entre
asiatiques et on va se débarrasser des
états unis aujourd'hui les instruments
sont en place pour pouvoir se passer les
transactions en dollars
faut pas avoir fait de longues études
pour savoir si la masse monétaire double
aux états unis et des changements en
chine va probablement dans les années
qui viennent la monnaie chinoise a monté
vis-à-vis de la monnaie américaine et
donc grosso modo il semble comme s'il
était un jeune homme jeune cheveux je
suivrai le conseil de parra l'est jeune
homme
pour une fois je paraphrase ray monsieur
macron 7 en marche
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les dames on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie
c'est à dire un état inefficace tout ça
a été financée essentiellement par de la
dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
devenez
21 heures heure de paris merci nous
rejoignent pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi 24
février
le couperet est tombé l'agglomération de
dunkerque confiner le week-end annonce
d'olivier verront sur place tout à
l'heure conférence de presse de jean
castex demain des restrictions locales
attendue alors que la situation
sanitaire est préoccupante dans une
dizaine de départements plus de 31 mille
nouveaux cas ont été enregistrés
aujourd'hui une première depuis novembre
le gouvernement veut agir au cas par cas
là où le variant britannique se propage
très rapidement
en espagne les manifestations se
poursuivent depuis l'arrestation du
rappeur pablo à z un sujet politique
domine également l'actualité en
catalogne
l'indépendantiste catalan caresse plus
du monde pourrait bientôt perdre son
immunité de député européen depuis la
belgique bataille contre son éventuelle
extradition
le ciel s'assombrit nouvelle fois pour
boeing
le gendarme américain l'aviation ont
ordonné une inspection en profondeur des
moteurs des boeing 777 tout le monde
sait flotte au sol une décision qui fait
suite à un incident survenu samedi
dernier sur un vol united airlines il
serait dû à la fatigue du métal des
pales du moteur du triple sec selon les
autorités
la situation sanitaire en france prise
de parole aujourd'hui de gabriélat
talent à l'issue des traditionnelles
conseil de défense sanitaire et conseil
des ministres mais également celle du
ministre de la santé en fin d'après-midi
à dunkerque les précisions de thomas
bonnet à dunkerque un confinement le
week-end qui prend effet dès cette
semaine le résultat d'une situation qui
s'est nettement dégradée dans la ville
du nord selon les dires du ministre de
la santé olivier ferrand qui était en
déplacement à dakar que ce mercredi en
ce moment un habitant sur 100 est
contaminée chaque semaine dans la ville
de dunkerque c'est pour cette raison que
les autorités ont donc décidé de prendre
des mesures supplémentaires écoutez
olivier veyrat ainsi à dunkerque et dans
la communauté de communes des hauts de
flandre ce qui représente environ 250000
habitants à compter de vendredi soir et
jusqu'au lundi matin un confinement sera
désormais adapter le week-end donc dès
ce week end les déplacements resteront
possibles pour certains motifs tels que
des achats de première nécessité ou
encore des motifs médicaux vous
connaissez ces motifs et les commerces
autre que les commerces alimentaires
seront fermés après nice la ville du
nord est donc également concernés par de
nouvelles mesures de restrictions
sanitaires un peu plus tôt dans la
journée le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent a tenu un point presse à
l'issue du conseil de défense sanitaire
et du conseil des ministres plusieurs
pistes sont sur la table nous dit on met
une option est à 7h15 tesselles d'art
confinement nationale écouter gabriela
talent tous nos efforts tous nos efforts
doivent se poursuivre pour éviter
d'avoir à décider d'un nouveau
confinement nationale sans évidemment
certitude que nous y parviendrons mais
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois c'est ce que vous
m'entendez vous dire mais nous avons une
stratégie cette stratégie je le disais
c'est la capacité à respecter les gestes
barrières les règles
un couvre-feu ce jeudi le premier
ministre jean castex tiendra une
conférence de presse à 18h une prise de
parole qui devrait être l'occasion
d'annoncer de nouvelles mesures ciblées
c'est la stratégie adoptée par le
gouvernement répondre de manière locale
en privilégiant des mesures coercitives
à l'échelle d'un département ou d'une
agglomération la question est donc de
savoir quels seront ces mesures et qui
pourraient être concernées selon le
porte parole du gouvernement
la situation s'est dégradée ces derniers
ces derniers jours dans une dizaine de
départements sur le territoire national
et un chiffre en atteste tout
particulièrement 31500 nouveaux cas
positifs ont été relevés ces dernières
24 heures en france une chose est sûre
en tout cas toujours selon à gabriel
atteindre un allègement des restrictions
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour et ce y
compris en ce qui concerne les régions
où le taux d'incidence est plus faible
qu'ailleurs le gouvernement qui espère
parallèlement intensifier la campagne de
vaccination dès ce jeudi les médecins de
ville pourront procéder aux injections
et demain jean castex prendra à son tour
la parole alors doit-on craindre un
confinement le week-end dans les
départements les plus touchés seriez
vous prêt à l'accepter
nous avons posé la question vaut
confinement total le week-end
s'ils prennent de telles mesures je
pense que c'est par rapport à tout ce
qui se passe donc c'est peut-être
nécessaire après c'est un peu compliqué
d'appliquer sa sur paris vous avez juste
à vous retourner à regarder un c'est le
seul moment où les parisiens ils
profitent c'est le week-end donc c'est
très compliqué je pense de faire ça sur
paris là on va concerner les gens en
fait les week-ends et avec l'arrivée du
printemps on va faire comment pour les
autres jours ces centres est aussi un
c'est archi mort ne se retourne pas à
ces morts déjà on n'est même pas qu'on
finit confinement à 18 heures je te
gâche pas on sort du studio il est déjà
22 heures 23 heures c'est mort ces morts
ces morts toi tu vois tu confies nettoie
des à paris à 18 heures la personne qui
est confiné il ya des régions jusqu'à 20
heures
mais c'est pas possible et en plus le
week end là il commence à faire beau
danse avec la crise si non c'est le
confinement le week end soit possible
qu'est ce que je vous dis si tout le
monde faisait attention mais chez ça
fait un an pour venir que je me confie
j'ai 79 ans j'ai eu deux pensées et je
n'ai rien c'est que je fais très
attention
le week end va écouter oui pourquoi pas
mais moi je trouve que c'est une mesure
qui n'est pas qu'il est inutile en fait
parce que regarder il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sortent dans la semaine mais
c'est pas le fait de confier le week-end
qui va changer les choses très pour
parler de la crise sanitaire en france
nous sommes avec philippe froguel
généticien professeur au chu de lille et
à l'impérial collège de londres bonsoir
philippe ringuette merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france où les
tout d'abord vous faire réagir sur ce
chiffre qui est tombée dans la soirée
plus de 30 mille carats même plus de
31000 cas de contamination 24 heures
c'est un record depuis novembre alors
qu'on nous disait la semaine dernière
que ça allait plutôt mieux qu est ce qui
s'est passé en une semaine
oui c'est passé ce qui devait se passer
c'est à dire le variés anglais est en
train de gagner du terrain il est à 95%
à dunkerque et nous non par séquençage
on le trouve à 34% à lille il va
augmenter va être à 50 % à la fin de la
semaine
donc il est 30% plus contagieux et et
entraîne des risques plus importants
être à l'hôpital
il se passe ce qu'on disait au
gouvernement depuis longtemps et qu'il
n'a pas envie d'entendre
donc j ai peut-être monsieur macron a
peut-être eu raison il ya trois semaines
ne pas faire le confinement
mais s'il croit que l'on va y échapper à
ce qui devait arriver baril a tort parce
que ça va vraiment arriver alors vous
avez vu que emmanuel macron n'est pas le
seul à parce que c'est vrai que les
français n'ont pas franchement envie
d'être reconfirmer sérieusement il ya
vraiment une inquiétude nous y sommes il
faut agir vite et bien ou c'est déjà en
quelque sorte trop tard pour vous moi
j'ai pas du tout envie d'être confiné
comme tout le monde et comme vous
probablement simplement je vois ce qui
se passe à dunkerque
dunkerque on est à 90 % au moins de
varier anglais les hôpitaux sont
complètement saturé il ya la moitié des
patients qui est qu'ils sont envoyés
ailleurs totalement chu de lille où il
ya encore de la place mais pour combien
de temps et ils sont à un taux
d'incidence qui énorme qui à peu près
celui le maximum qu'on a vu en france
était à 1100 c'était à roubaix au moins
de novembre donc oui on est dans une
situation extrêmement extrêmement
extrêmement difficile je pense qu'on a
eu raison de faire quelque chose à
dunkerque je pense qu'ensuite on fera la
même chose dont le reste des autres
france et puis ensuite dans les régions
où c'est aussi très très difficile on
peut le regretter moi ça va être bien
entendu je vais le regretter énormément
en tant que citoyen et en tant que
médecin je vois bien la difficulté
alors philippe froguel c'est vrai qu'on
parle de re confiné confinement enfin on
oubliait un petit peu vite un mot si les
journalistes bêtement on parle de
confinement enfin on oublie quand même
qu'on est confinée depuis des semaines
on couvre feu et que là il s'agit d'un
confinement le week-end
alors est ce que c'est vraiment efficace
ces petites touches à droite à gauche le
week-end alors on aura droit de
travailler c'est super mais est ce que
ça va faire baisser vraiment le
virus de confiner le week end la réponse
telle qu'on l'a vu dans d'autres pays un
nom en angleterre ils ont fait un
confinement beaucoup plus important ils
ont ils ont fermé les écoles
mes filles qui habitent là peuvent pas
se voir les unes les autres et il a
fallu plusieurs mois pour que ça diminue
enfin pour se débarrasse des variés
anglais et on l'a réussi parce que il
vaccine cinq fois plus qu'en france
donc la situation française est vraiment
inquiétante alors elle est pas pareil
dans la bretagne par rapport à dunkerque
eu certes mais je pense que dans trois
semaines quatre semaines et variés
anglais ce sera le variant français et
ensuite il y aura d'autres aux anomalies
qui vont apparaître du mali génétique
il va falloir surveiller maintenant
est-ce qu'il faut confiné c'est très
très difficile parce que sans
vaccination très importante et c'est là
où on est vraiment vraiment problème par
rapport à l'angleterre aux états unis ou
israël ou de certains autres pays
ça va être très difficile de sortir
facilement du confinement
alors c'est vrai qu'en plus il ya les
enfants qui vont revenir à l'école à
laon nous sommes en période de vacances
scolaires on nous promet des tests
salivaires c
c'est suffisant pour pas trop propager
ce variant anglais qu'on dit très
contagieux y compris chez les jeunes
est-ce que c'est l'hiver ça fait neuf
mois que mes amis de france baissent le
demandons enfin on va les avoir ça va
certifier un petit peu les choses
ça va permettre de diagnostiquer des
gens qui sinon c'est éristique est pas
sa part changer fondamentalement le
problème le problème c'est si on était
dans une situation idéale
on fera un confinement près serré et
incombe et en même temps la vaccination
très important mais on n'est pas capable
de faire les vaccinations très
importante et donc on sait très bien que
si on fait un confinement serré ça
changera pas fondamentalement les choses
donc on est dans une situation vivre
avec le virus plutôt que les ridicules
alors il ya un cycle qui nous est
parvenue aujourd'hui par la bouche du
ministre de la santé une moyenne d'âge
qui baissent de 2,7 ans manifestement à
l'hôpital vous parliez vaccination c'est
l'incidence heureuse des premières
vaccinations en france est la preuve que
la vaccination marche
c'est la preuve définitive on a eu la
même chose en angleterre ou en israël
mais en france ça marche il ya à peu
près à 40% environ des morts de qu'ovide
qui sont dans les ehpad hésite pas de 6
à 7 750 une personne seulement mais un
tiers des morts ont au minimum
maintenant 80 % des patients des
personnes des ehpad alors sur moi une
injection et vous voyez que c'est très
efficace puisque la mortalité des ehpad
diminue extraordinairement donc oui ça
marche
le vrai question c'est comment se
fait-il que l'europe a pas été capable
de vacciner les européens alors en même
temps que les anglais eux mêmes les
américains ça c'est un autre débat on
aurait pas assez de temps pour pour
l'évoquer ici autre chiffre
stéphane fait par dont philippe froguel
7% des adultes de plus de 20 ans dans
l'hexagone ont été infectées par le
corridor entre le début de la pandémie
il 16 février c'est l'institut pasteur
qu'il dit est ce que c'est
est un chiffre dont on peut tirer des
enseignements au finalement ça veut rien
dire à partir du moment où ou l'immunité
d'ailleurs et des très loin de de ce
chiffre la l'immunité collective et
qu'en plus on peut peut-être attraper le
combine une seconde fois où ça peut
quand même nous dire quelque chose de
plaisant c'est un résultat parmi
d'autres parce que c'est c'est un peu
aléatoire en mesure sert un certain andy
corps il peut y avoir d'autres types
d'immunité bon disons qu'on a entre 20
et 30% de la population qui a rencontré
déjà le virus que celle que c'est pas
l'immunité collective
si on arrive à limiter collective va
falloir vacciner en entre 50 et 60% de
la population et tout le monde sait bien
que les promesses du président parce que
valent les promesses et que alors quand
en angleterre tout le monde sera à peu
près vacciner au mois de juin mois mes
deux filles même qu'à 24 ans et 32 ans
ont été vaccinés
dimanche dernier combien de jeunes en
france sont vaccinés à l'âge de 30 ans
aucun et donc ça c'est un problème sauf
si l'angleterre en totalité et vaccinés
et que l'europe ne l'est pas ça va être
compliqué pour les britanniques de de se
maintenir en sécurité néanmoins les
frontières vont être heureuses on va
avoir des énormes problèmes on sera
parmi les plus mauvais en france sur le
taux de gens vaccinés ce qui veut dire
que voir des problèmes pour les
touristes aussi problème pour les
français pour les étrangers ils vont
exiger probablement des passeports de
vaccination ont les anglais we peut y
avoir quelque chose
tout dépend de type de virus corner en
france ah si le et si on a des mutants
qui résiste aux 26 nations antérieures
effectivement il faut surtout pas que
les anglais viennent si on n'a que des
le encore que des virus qui circule en
france qui sont contrôlés par la
vaccination ça sera correct pour les
anglais
merci philippe froguel en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france généticien professeur au chu
les à l'impérial collège de londres à
merci d'avoir été en direct hop une
fuite sans précédent les données
médicales de près de cinq cent mille
français ont été dérobés et publiée sur
internet sans demande de rançon une
trentaine de la boe utilisant a priori
le même logiciel sont concernés les
explications des stèles farges 491 1840
exactement c'est le nombre de fichiers
de patients français qui ont été volés
et diffusée sur internet
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont révélé nos
confrères de libération
dans chacun de ces fichiers des
informations ultra sensibles comme le
nom des patientes leurs coordonnées
leurs numéros de sécurité sociale et
même pour certains des annotations sur
leur état de santé
fait étonnant ces données ont été mises
en ligne gratuitement
c'est un fichier à valeurs fortes avec
des noms des adresses des coordonnées
des numéros de sécurité sociale
en plus de la fuite en elle-même le fait
que ces informations étaient des mises
en ligne gratuitement est extrêmement
perturbant et inquiétant selon le site
de vérification des faits de libération
tchèque news toutes ces données
appartiendrait tu as une trentaine de
laboratoires et correspondrait à des
prélèvements médicaux réalisés entre
2015 et 2020 durant cette période les
laboratoires concernés par ce larcin
aurait utilisé le même logiciel de
saisie de données médicales
nous n'avons aucune certitude quant au
fait que ce soit uniquement un logiciel
daedalus france qui est en cause dans
cette affaire nous avons mis en place
une cellule de crise car nous prenons
cela au sérieux et nous allons
travailler en partenariat avec nos
clients pour comprendre ce qu'il s'est
passé
d'après damien bancal hauteur du bloc
zataz premier à avoir identifié cette
gigantesque fuite
une dispute entre pirate informatique
aurait déclenché la publication de ces
fichiers médicaux
toujours est il qu outre le vol et la
violation du caractère ô combien privée
de ces données les patients présents
dans ce fichier peuvent devenir des
cible pour les pirates informatiques les
personnes y figurant sont des cibles de
choix pour du phishing personnalisés
envoi de faux messages ou de faux
documents pour récupérer des
informations personnelles ou de l'argent
d'éventuels pirates disposent désormais
de leur numéro de sécurité sociale du
nom de leur médecin prescripteur de la
date de leur examen du nom du
laboratoire ou encore dans certains cas
d'informations médicales
ajoutez à cela le risque d'usurpation
d'identité et vous obtenez un cocktail
explosif pour des gens mal intentionnés
ces dernières semaines les
établissements liés à la santé sont
devenus des cibles privilégiées pour les
pirates informatiques
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information révèle que depuis
le début de l'année une attaque par
semaine et portées contre un hôpital
français et on en parlait tout à l'heure
l'institut pasteur qui a publié une
étude sur la proportion de la population
française infectés par le kobe de 19 sur
la base des résultats des tests
sérologiques mais également selon les
chiffres des hospitalisations et décès
liés à la pandémie
la fondation privée publiée un rapport
par région et par tranche d'âge les
précisions en images
[Musique]
beaucoup beaucoup
oh
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
jérôme rodriguez sera fixé le 6 avril au
cur heures lui demande la relaxe figure
du mouvement des gilet jaune
il comparaissait devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris aujourd'hui lui
reprocher d'avoir injurié des policiers
sur twitter en septembre dernier dans un
échange de messages avec le syndicat de
police synergie
il avait alors fait une analogie entre
les forces de l'ordre et le régime nazi
évoquant également un conte
concentration dans le nord-est de paris
mais il se dit intérieur gérald darmanin
avait qualifié ces propos d' ignoble
annonçant qu'une plainte allait être
déposée écoutez la réaction de jérôme
rodriguez à l'issue de sa comparution
devant le tribunal correctionnel unsa
mieux que moi ce que j'ai dit que j'ai
insulté la police
non non les gars allez écrire des films
il serait beaucoup meilleure affaire ça
que de prétendre que moi j'ai dit j'ai
dit bon de l'asie et ça s'adresse aux
syndicats tout simplement au bénéfice du
doute
en tous les cas il y a il a honte je
suis même pas certain qu'il ait le bush
pour ce qu'il est c'est confirmé je ne
m'adresse pas tout la police donc il a
demandé la relaxe
on continue aujourd'hui à faire passer
rodriguez pour 1,1 mde coeur et medi 1
et 2 des keufs alors que c'est pas vrai
on continue à faire passer rodriguez
pour le plus violent des violents alors
que c'est pas vrai c'est tout j'ai pas
de casier je suis pas violent moi je
suis là pour militer pour les droits
sociales et fiscales je la prenais mieux
vivre de l'ensemble de mes camarades je
suis là pour faire en sorte d'avoir une
démo qu'à sion est directe et
participative et de mettre fin à toutes
les saloperies contraint de mettre en
place aujourd'hui le gouvernement
d'accord aujourd'hui les responsables
c'est pas les keufs d'accord elle est
responsable c'est le gouvernement qui
utilise les flics pour mettre en place
un bouclier pour les protéger de leur
connerie c'est la seule chose
dans le reste de l'actualité en géorgie
le nouveau premier ministre lance un
appel au dialogue après les
manifestations monstres qui ont secoué
la capitale tbilissi en cause
l'arrestation du principal opposant au
pouvoir ni camélia les manifestants
réclament sa libération
amaya soul et une arrestation qui a
secoué l'opposition en géorgie ni
camélia leader du mouvement national uni
a été délogé mardi matin des locaux de
sa formation politique afin d'être placé
en détention provisoire
une arrestation musclée violente des
centaines de policiers ont fait usage de
bombes lacrymogènes contre tous les
partis d'opposition qui campaient devant
le bâtiment
les militants du parti ont immédiatement
dénoncé cette arrestation
nous avons assisté à l'arrestation du
plus grand chef du parti d'opposition
dans ses propres locaux sous le prétexte
le plus cynique en utilisant les
instruments les plus honteux et
évidemment c'est un défi pour l'avenir
et la liberté de ce pays
il est de notre devoir en tant que
citoyen en tant que société de résister
en manifestant dans les rues par des
manifestations pacifiques mais très
intense
des milliers de manifestants sont
descendus dans les rues de géorgie pour
protester contre l'arrestation denis
camélia dans un contexte de crise
politique qui pourrait fragiliser un peu
plus la démocratie
en effet depuis les élections
législatives d'octobre 2020 les
différents partis d'opposition dénoncent
un scrutin truqué
bref géorgien le parti au pouvoir avait
revendiqué une courte victoire alors que
sa popularité décline sur fond de
stagnation économique et de dénonciation
d'atteintes à la démocratie lundi le
parlement a confirmé la nomination par
eve géorgien d'irakli garibal vili au
poste de premier ministre qui a
immédiatement annoncé l'arrestation
denis camélias le gouvernement a de son
côté évoqué un usage proportionné de la
force et la polarisation d'une politique
due à des délinquants
le premier ministre géorgien appelle
tous les partis de l'opposition au
dialogue et à l'apaisement
aujourd'hui le ministère de l'intérieur
a appliqué une loi nécessaire à la
réduction du radicalisme politique et à
l'établissement de relations équitables
quand les a reçus ma réaction du peuple
à l'application de la loi a confirmé que
l'état de droit est la principale
priorité du peuple géorgien concept
shona lowe et whitman cependant nous ne
comptons pas le nombre de personnes
rassemblées pour la manifestation
chaque citoyen de notre pays nous est
précieux place aux arçons
aujourd'hui maintenant que la loi est
appliquée que l'état a pris la place qui
lui est due
je voudrais appeler toutes les forces
politiques qui tiennent à notre pays à
ouvrir un dialogue réel et sérieux à
parler non pas de ce qui nous divise
mais de ce qui doit nous unir le pays
est confronté à des défis il est temps
de dialoguer pas de se confronter ni
camélia est accusé d'avoir organisé des
violences de masse lors de
manifestations en 2019 et risque neuf
ans de prison
des accusations qu'ils réfutent et juge
politique la scène internationale se dit
inquiète pour l'équilibré du pays
la violence et le chaos à tbilissi
ils sont la dernière chose dont la
géorgie a besoin en ce moment j'exhorte
tous les partis à agir avec retenue
maintenant et dans les jours à venir la
décision d'arrêter un opposant politique
avait la semaine dernière inquiéter
l'union européenne et les etats-unis
appelant à séparer le système judiciaire
de tout parti pris politique
ce vendredi l'opposition appelle à une
nouvelle marche à tbilissi et est avec
nous nous parlerons dans quelques
instants de caresses prix du monde
indépendantiste catalan qui pourrait
bientôt perdre son immunité de député
européen depuis la belgique une bataille
contre son éventuelle extradition
et puis nous reviendrons sur l'incident
survenu samedi dernier sur un vol united
airlines le gendarme oad américain de
l'aviation a ordonné une inspection en
profondeur des moteurs des tripes cpta
[Musique]
je
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sent du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune c'était
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
ah bon les femmes bon quart et la demie
les femmes ce qui a été l'histoire
jusqu'à maintenant était biaisé
[Musique]
pour l'histoire de l'art d'ailleurs la
problématique est bien là pour
l'histoire de l'art c'est marginal il a
fallu vraiment des femmes génial très
très doué pour arriver à trouver une
place dans un domaine où rien n'était
prévu pour elle
[Musique]
ces femmes artistes ne s'en sont sortis
que parce qu'elle avait les tripes
vraiment bien accroché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier
à quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos j'ai
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je j'essaie de faire au mieux
c'est aussi tout un questionnement sur
la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le mans dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois ci il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
soyez bienvenus 21h30 en direct sur rt
france en espagne à les manifestations
pour soutenir le rappeur catalan pablo
hazell se poursuivent inlassablement
chaque soir des rassemblements sont
organisés en catalogne pour protester
contre la condamnation à neuf mois de
prison ferme pour apologie du terrorisme
et l encontre de la monarchie elle
concerne 64 tweets publiés entre 2014 et
2016 est une chanson sur l'ancien roi
d'espagne juan carlos
les précisions de l'esprit issing là
notre correspondante sur place le
premier ministre socialiste pedro
sanchez l'a condamné les violences des
manifestants il a expliqué que c'est une
atteinte à la liberté d'autrui que c'est
inadmissible en démocratie et que rien
ne justifie la violence
il a également expliqué que le
gouvernement espagnol garantir la
sécurité des citoyens
de l'autre côté la gauche de podemos n'a
pas condamner clairement les émeutes il
ya même le porte parole au parlement qui
a expliqué qu'il soutenait les jeunes
anti-fascistes qui demandent la liberté
dans la rue selon ses propres mots alors
ça crée des tensions puisque les deux
partis forment une coalition
gouvernementale
il ya seulement la mère de barcelone à
dakola aux apparentés à podemos qui a
déclaré que la défense de la liberté
d'expression ne justifie pas le
vandalisme car après plus d'une semaine
de mobilisation et les dégâts sont
estimés à plus d'un million d'euros est
liée à des magasins vandalisés des
containers brûlés du mobilier urbain
saccagé en catalogne au total une
centaine de personnes ont été arrêtées
et ce soir marque le neuvième jour de
rassemblements consécutifs
le pro indépendantiste catalan carles
esprit que je monte en passe de perdre
son immunité et la commission des
affaires juridiques du parlement
européen a approuvé hier sa demande de
levée de l'immunité deux autres députés
européens indépendantistes sont
également concernés la mesure sera
soumise au vote des eurodéputés lors de
la session plénière du parlement début
mars
car esprit jones est visé par un mandat
d'arrêt émis par l'espagne entre autres
pour sédition à la suite d'une tentative
de sécession de sa région en 2017
l'ancien président de catalogne s'est
depuis réfugié en belgique d'où ils
dénoncent la nature politique de la
procédure engagée au parlement européen
la décision du comité des affaires
légales du parlement européen il a
précisé que prévisible il la montagnarde
et cherchait vraiment à plat si sa cave
h à 15 h tribune iht apte à sa vocation
européen
si on nous retire notre initiale et la
démocratie européenne sera marquée par
un passage très négative à chinon et les
emiratis politiques représentés citoyen
européen
annie walker qui chanteront sera moins
jeunes ont comme l'avatar ya pas de rire
nous et comme bataille n'est jamais les
faits sont ce qu'ils sont et nous
n'allons rien céder à quitter ce soit
jusqu'à la dernière minute
la dernière s'est installée dimanche el
mundo
et pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
ignacy fortuny coordinateur de
l'assemblée nationale catalane en france
bonsoir ignazi forte unie merci
avec mon en direct sur ac france une
première réaction à ce vote c'était
prévisible
bonsoir oui c'était prévisible compte
tenu de la composition de cette
commission
il ne faut pas oublier que les députés
européens espagnols
dès qu'il a fallu constituer depuis la
dernière les dernières élections
européennes
ici ils ont essayé de se placer de longs
afin de pouvoir noter cette commission
ce qui est assez surprenant c'est le
nombre de dés de députés espagnols dans
cette commission qui est disproportionné
par rapport à ça aux députés européens
provenant d'autres pays a dénoncé un
vote politique c'est votre avis
également totalement politique
d'ailleurs je pense que l'europe devrait
beaucoup réfléchir sur ce vote et en
particulier le vote qui va avoir lieu
aux alentours de 10 mars par l'assemblée
plénière
car j'estime et tout le monde en
catalogne et park en catalogne mais tous
les démocrates européens considèrent que
c'est un une décision qui payent qui
constituera un précédent et qui peut
être extrêmement dangereuses compte tenu
de la violation des libertés
fondamentales en europe et ce site est
extrêmement négatif comme l'a précisé le
président carlos ghosn tout à l'heure
dans les conférences de presse que vous
avez montré il ya quelques minutes
alors il ya quand même des faits on
reprochait d'avoir organisé on le
rappelle un référendum totalement
illégale des fraudes auraient été
abondamment prouvé ce n'est pas votre
avis non pas du tout d'abord il faut
tenir compte que le président tout ce
monde comme les membres du gouvernement
catalan en 2017 n'ont fait qu'exécuter
les le programme pour lequel il avait
été élu en tout cas il faudrait
reprocher ça au peuple catalan d'avoir
voté ce qui est c'est ce gouvernement ce
qui est quand même assez surprenant
c'est que ceux ci
nous remet à un point important c'est
que en espagne aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
de liberté d'opinion plus de liberté
d'exercice de la politique pour tous
laissé certains sujets qui sont à bout
et notamment celui de l'indépendance de
la catalogne
or les ce gouvernement a été élu pour
négocier à veritas pagnol l'indépendance
et un référendum d'indépendance l'état
espagnol a toujours refusé de négocier
quoi que ce soit ils ont toujours il y a
eu 17 réunions pour essayer de trouver
de débloquer situation et de trouver une
solution au conflit
ç'a toujours été non non non et non et
que par conséquent en tant que groupe
que membre d'un gouvernement
démocratiquement élu
ils ont essayé d'exercer le droit des
citoyens de pouvoir s'exprimer
alors ça c'est donc pour les parties pis
la partie fait ce sont les accusations
c'était le cas aujourd'hui devant la
cour les accusations de détournement de
fonds et de sédition les accusations de
détournement de fonds pareil ce sont des
fausses déclarations
ce sont des fausses accusations le
gouvernement espagnol prétend que le
fait d'avoir utilisé des fonds publics
pour organiser un référendum qu'ils
considèrent ils ont considéré qu'il
était illégale constitue un détournement
de fonds publics
notamment il faut tenir compte d'un
autre élément c'est que une grande
partie de ces référendum a été organisé
gratuitement par l'ensemble de la
population puisque les institutions de
la de l'état espagnol ont mis toutes les
entraves possibles et inimaginables pour
empêcher l'exercice du droit de vote aux
citoyens et d'autre part en ce qui
concerne la sédition
il n'y a pas de sédition sont d'autant
plus que le concept de sédition dans le
code pénal espagnol est un concept vieux
concept qui a disparu partout en europe
tel qu'il est défini par le code pénal
espagnol et notamment il est important
de
pelé c'est que lorsque monsieur le
président de la junte at monsieur carlos
pizza mode a été arrêté et jugé dans le
cadre d'une demande d'extradition de
l'espagne en allemagne le tribunal
supérieur de justice du land de
schleswig holstein a justement refusé de
retenir le concept de sédition entre
autres parce que ce concept n'existe
même pas dans le droit allemand alors
qu'à respecte on doit maintenant passer
en session plénière clairement vous
craignez qu'il se rapproche de
l'extradition
alors moi je suis beaucoup plus prudent
il est vrai que il y à des prises de
très fortes pressions de l'état espagnol
et que parfois la les institutions
européennes ont trop tendance à tourner
la tête et à ignorer ce qui se passe en
espagne car il n'y a pas que le problème
catalan les libertés fondamentales sont
de constamment remise en cause en
espagne comme on l'a vu et vous l'avez
montré tout à l'heure concernant les des
chanteurs et des rappeurs mais aussi
faut tenir compte d'un daim et d'un
élément
important c'est que le président paul
damon dans le cadre de de cette
procédure qui a été engagé il
il faut tenir compte de deux éléments
d'une part maintenant ça sera voté par
l'assemblée plénière
quant aux résultats l'assemblée plénière
je ne sais pas encore nous n'avons pas
d'éléments suffisants pour voir quel
pourrait être le résultat
autant nous étions convaincus que le du
résultat de la commission des affaires
juridiques
mais concernant l'assemblée plénière
j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de
députés qui comprendront que c'est les
libertés fondamentales qui risque d'être
remis en cause au sein même de toute
l'union européenne
deuxièmement une fois l'assemblée
plénière aura pris une décision si cette
décision est de confirmer
la commission des affaires juridiques du
parlement européen il y a encore la
possibilité d'un recours devant la cour
de justice de l'union européenne
et si la cour de justice confirmait
encore la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire ce n'est qu'à ce moment-là
l'extradition devraient être traitées
par les droits nationaux nationaux des
pays de résidence de ces de ses députés
européens c'est-à-dire la belgique et
qu'il existe comme contrairement à ce
qu'a fait cet le rapport de cette
commission d'ignorer les décisions
allemandes et belges
la justice belge a déjà dans d'autres
affaires concernant des indépendantistes
catalans a déjà refusé l'extradition de
ces indépendantistes l'espagne merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct et franc
les déboires de boeing au chapitre ii
après le feu d'un réacteur samedi au
dessus de denver aux états unis une
pluie de débris est tombé sur la
banlieue de la ville
aucun blessé mais le constructeur n'en
est pas à son premier incident et se
trouve plus que jamais dans le viseur de
l'administration fédérale américaine de
l'aviation florian lambert une pluie de
débris qui s'abat sous la banlieue de
denver
un réacteur droit qui prend feu et une
frayeur immense pour les 231 passagers
du boeing 777
après une panne spectaculaire samedi
dernier place désormais à l'inspection
des moteurs concernés
l'administration fédérale américaine de
l'aviation at en effet décidé de faire
subir un examen approfondi des pales des
moteurs de ses boeing avant qu'ils
puissent voler de nouveau
nous voulons comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et prendre les mesures nécessaires
afin d'éviter qu'un événement similaires
se reproduisent à l'avenir la fédération
américaine de l'aviation a examiné
toutes les données de sécurité
disponibles après l'incident selon les
premières conclusions de l'enquêté les
dommages constatés sur place sont
compatibles avec une fatigue du métal
des pales de la soufflante du moteur à
la suite de l'incident de samedi dernier
qui n'a fait aucun blessé 128 appareils
dont 60,9 en service ont été immobilisés
par boeing un incident qui pourrait
affecter le marché mondial de l'aviation
le royaume-uni at-on effet décidé
d'interdire son espace aérien au boeing
777 concernés pour cause boeing n'en est
pas à son premier accroc à partir de
2019 son fleuron le 737 max est cloué au
sol pendant près de deux ans après deux
accidents ayant fait 346 mort si
l'incident de samedi dernier l'a fait
aucun blessé
il représente un nouveau revers pour
boeing dont le titre a perdu plus de 2%
lundi en bourse très pour en parler nous
sommes avec michel polacco journalistes
spécialistes aéronautiques hauteur de
crash pourquoi des avions s'écrasent
t-il encore éditions hachette bonsoir
michel
aux échos merci d'être avec nous que
vous inspire tout d'abord ces incidents
une pluie de débris sur le triple sept
au départ de denver et puis sur les
pays-bas des débris cette fois ci du 747
400 beaucoup plus vieux bien sûr mais
est ce normal que les avis vont les
avions tombent en miettes au dessus de
nos têtes
normal que les avions tombent en miettes
au dessus de nos têtes
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas le cas en fait
de temps en temps hélas des moteurs se
détruisent envol c'est arrivé plusieurs
fois vous avez vu le cadre ce boeing 747
anciens mais c'est arrivé en fait ces
dernières années ces dix dernières
années sur les trois très gros modèles
d'avions plutôt de moteur qui existent
dans le monde
c'est arrivé sur un airbus a380 de la
qantas en 2010 avec un moteur rolls
royce
c'est arrivé sur un airbus a380 d'air
france en 2010 7 avec des moteurs engine
alliance c'est à dire general electric
et pratt & whitney et là ça arrive avec
un moteur pratt & whitney 4077 sur un
boeing 777
en fait on sait maintenant depuis
quelques mois je peux dire que il y a
des problèmes de fatigue de métal sur
les très gros moteurs d'avion le bureau
d'enquêtés et d'analysés français a fait
une étude très intéressante à l'occasion
de l' enquête qui a été fait sur ce qui
s'était produit au dessus du groenland
avec un vol d'air france et ils ont
découvert un phénomène qu'on appelle la
fatigue douelle et qui est en fait un
phénomène de dégradation des métaux
précieux comme le titane qui est
utilisée parce qu'il est extrêmement
résistant et peu lourd et qui avec le
temps peut se dégrader notamment
provoqué des dégradations des pales or
les pales vous le savez tourne à des
vitesses très élevées
un moteur d'avion ça tourne autour de 20
mille tours à peu près la minute et donc
lorsqu'une pale se brise se détache ça
provoque des dégâts qui normalement
doivent être contenues par le moteur
heures c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que les
moteurs sont certifiés mais on a vu
aussi bien pour le vol de qantas que le
vol d'air france que pour ce vol qu'il
ya quand même des débris qui ne sont pas
contenus et c'est très ennuyeux
oui oui alors michel polacco si vous
êtes en train de terroriser tous les
gens qui ont déjà peur de l'avion ce
phénomène d'usure des métaux est ce que
c'est un phénomène récent et seront
fabrique des avions de moins bonne
qualité aujourd'hui on sonne à rien à
voir ça a toujours existé sauf que
peut-être que voilà on s'en était moins
rendu compte alors en fait si vous
voulez les problèmes de fatigue du métal
toujours existé simplement avec le temps
on a fait des progrès considérables en
matière de travail sur les métaux et de
traitement des métaux aussi bien lors du
de la fabrication du coulage que de
l'usinage et c est penser que sur les
très très gros moteur moteur qu'il faut
le rappeler tourner quelques fois
pendant 15 17 heures 18 heures par jour
voire plus on était à l'abri de
problèmes de fatigue de métal parce
qu'on avait mis des métaux comme le
titane duc est un métal rare et qui est
assez léger en quantité assez importante
pour pouvoir supporter les charges et
les efforts qui sont qui se produisent
lors de ces vols sur les très très gros
moteurs encore une fois je le dis et
donc sur les très très gros avion et on
a vécu comme ça quelques années je
dirais confortable et puis maintenant on
découvre avec le temps que en fait il ya
des phénomènes qui n'ont pas été connus
qui ne se détecte pas facilement lors
des inspections et qui peuvent se
produire alors ça s'est produit
en fait sur les trois accidents que je
vous ai cité s'est produit deux fois
donc c'est pas énorme quand on compare
aux 40 millions de vols se font chaque
année avec des avions de ligne mais
c'est quand même toujours trop parce que
un jour ça peut déboucher sur un
accident grave
voire mortelles heureusement pour
l'instant ce n est pas ce qui s'est
produit
mais les laboratoires car hélas il
s'agit vraiment de laboratoire des
producteurs de métaux travaille là
dessus les constructeurs de moteurs
travaille là dessus évidemment les
constructeurs d'avions dépend totalement
de et pour l'instant ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on multiplie les contrôles on les
rend beaucoup plus fréquent de manière à
pouvoir détecter tout tout risque de
défaillance
et cette formule apparemment est
suffisant simplement sur le boeing 777
200 300 équipés des moteurs pratt &
whitney 4077 eh bien on n'était pas très
méfiants parce que c'est un avion qui a
trente ans maintenant et que donc ces
moteurs sont des moteurs très éprouvés
et qu'on ne pensait pas que ça allait se
produire à l'image là vous avez un mode
un avion très particulier c'est le jumbo
de boeing qui sert à transporter les
morceaux d'avion
ce n'est pas un avion de 10 alors 735,8
tout à fait 737 max c'était l'avion qui
avait été interdite de vol en mars 2010
neuf après deux accidents on se souvient
qu'il avait fait 346 mort on rajoute à
cela
effectivement la crise sanitaire et ces
derniers incidents sur le triple sept
est-ce que clairement ça peut être
vraiment une très mauvaise passe vous
voir la fin pour boeing ou c'est un peu
prématuré la fin de bail il n'en est pas
question baux signés du temps d'une
entreprise immense qui travaillent dans
le domaine militaire spatial civil et
qui a de très nombreuses activités même
si aujourd'hui elle à 60 milliards de
dollars de dettes
même si l'année dernière elle a perdu 20
milliards de dollars essentiellement à
cause de la crise du boeing 737 max on
va dire que boeing n'est pas en danger
de disparaître
maintenant la division avions civils de
boeing traverse une passe très très
difficile comme le dit
certaines célébrités françaises les
emmerdements volent toujours en
escadrille
et c'est vrai que pauline ya eu des
soucis avec à peu près tous ses modèles
depuis deux ans soit des problèmes de
cellules soit des problèmes de moteurs
ge que des problèmes lors des essais en
vol etc etc et que tout cela combiné
fait que bailly en ce moment produit
avec la crise a bien sûr en plus ce
produit très très peu d'avions nous en
produisent entre deux et trois fois
moins qu airbus et deuxièmement leurs
avions sont des avions qui pour une
bonne part sont des avions anciens qui
ont été rénovés plusieurs fois et qui
donc sont évidemment pas les vedettes du
marché donc bolling est en situation
délicate
même si c'est une entreprise qui
fabrique des très bons et très beaux
avions mais son catalogue commence à
dater
et il est vrai que boeing besoin d'une
très sérieuse reprise en main merci
michel polacco d'avoir été avec nous à
voir apporter votre expertise mercier
bull dont le reste de l'actualité le
sénégal a lancé hier sa campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vie 19 grâce à
l'acquisition récente de deux cent mille
doses de vaccin du chinois sinopharm
dont 10% ont été mis à la disposition de
ces deux de ses voisins à la guinée
bissau et la gambie
les précisions de françois xavier
lambert c'est devant la presse et en
présence de nombreuses personnalités que
les autorités sénégalaises ont lancé
leur campagne de vaccination contre le
coc vie 19
le ministre de la santé ainsi reçu une
dose du vaccin produit par le
laboratoire chinois sinopharm le sénégal
avait déjà reçu la semaine dernière 200
milles 12 du sérum qui affiche une
efficacité de 79%
le vaccin est déjà utilisé par plusieurs
pays africains
mais le sénégal et le premier situé en
afrique de l'ouest a lancé sa campagne
une vaccination qui concernera dans un
premier temps 20 mille membres du
personnel de santé
des personnes âgées sénégal aujourd'hui
fait partie des sept pays parmi les 54
pays du continent africain à avoir
démarré la vaccination
le sénégal attend également de recevoir
des 12 à travers l'initiative kovacs
piloté par l' oms les autorités négocier
avec d'autres pays notamment la russie
qui va lui fournir son accent spoutnik v
depuis fin novembre le pays est
confronté à une forte augmentation des
cas de kovy de 19 pour les autorités
sanitaires sénégalaises le vaccin est
l'unique solution car l'heure actuelle
la vaccination constitue que la très
vaste
on ne peut pas fonctionner et j'appelle
toutes les populations à se faire
vacciner
je les fais parce qu'il faut joindre
l'acte à la parole
pas con c'est les gens
cette campagne de vaccination démarre
sur fond de polémique
les occidentaux ont accumulé les doses
de vaccin au détriment de nombreux pays
pauvres et notamment africains le
président sénégalais ainsi demandé à
emmanuel macron de veiller au partage
des vaccins reçus par les pays les plus
riches
le président français a proposé que
l'europe et les états unis livre le plus
vite possible 13 millions de doses aux
pays africains et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci d'avoir suivi prochain
point complet sur l'actualité dans
quelques instants avec emilie gogh h
[Musique]